used it looked all like tricked out it
had like the wheels and the springs and
everything and then um he got shot at
because the Dude thought that it was the
previous owner oh [ __ ]
[Music]
uh Ryan have you ever enjoyed Ferraris I
feel like you haven't but uh I like them
yeah but I only like a specific one and
it's the one from Magnum PI because it's
that 80s one
is that a Testarossa no it's like the um
it's the one it's a smaller one it's the
one that uh that what's his name Tom
Selleck drives does it look more like a
Porsche uh no it's smaller than that
what about Ferraris like this guy
oh that's pretty cool sweet one pretty
sweet nice pretty sweet that's a Ferrari
tortellini is it yep
is that a pasta yeah
it's uh that's a Martinelli right there
now Ferrari's first crazy man it's too
it's too intense of a brand like the
whole thing about they're very proud you
can't really they get so pissed when you
[ __ ] with the car and you do anything
different they're like very they're like
purist and you know they're they want to
choose who gets their cars I've never
even sat on one before have you ever sat
in one you have a sound you lose for
sure said one see I've seen once I never
said one before well this Ferrari uh is
actually uh on bid for forty thousand
dollars right now what what's wrong with
it is it Mexican is it haunted why would
you say it's mixed again so there's also
kit cars you guys know what kit cars
what's a kit car so uh people will build
like the internals out of something else
like a theater
or you get like a Celica or like you buy
semi-expensive parts like a Lotus frame
or whatever and they build like carbon
fiber and all that other stuff and you
end up getting like a Lambo for like 50
Grand it looks like a Lambo on the
outside it is not a kid car no no does
it have water damage no there's no
damage to it keep growing with Sarah
keep going there's no six people died in
it nobody died in it annihilated nobody
died in it it doesn't work
yeah
it works it totally works we're right
there it doesn't Rari it rari's for sure
what other situation any any so we're
right there we're right there starting
bid is 40G someone said someone died in
it no no that's what Ken said not died I
said it was haunted it was haunted is it
haunted it's not haunted thank you the
starting beans it's being auctioned did
it belongs for a charity in what
situation oh was it was it seized oh
there it is
is for charity is very nice of you
you're such a sweet guy dude you know me
yeah not really
um
so this was a previously owned Ferrari
by a narco boss right oh now that they
should start it at like 5 million yeah
that's sweet
dude imagine buying El Chapo's Ferrari
what if he wants it back though yeah
[Laughter]
it's cheap because
I want it I'm not touching anything
with no cartel members yeah that's got
bad energy I'm stepping up seriously hey
that's my car like absolutely it is
there you go the pink slip I was just
holding on for you for a second yeah you
got the keys to my ass too yeah if you
want is there if you want it I'm just
damn just like oh [ __ ] Nick told me
about this day
that [ __ ] happens for sure yeah the
Colombian government is auctioning off
at least three Ferraris seized from an
alleged member of the clan Del Golfo and
says it will give the process proceeds
back to the people that's so dumb dude
they shouldn't even if they really want
to sell it they shouldn't have made a
public announcement that that's who's
yeah is that cartel still around private
[ __ ] sales read like hide the fact
that it was ever a narco card until you
see that pink slip says El Chapo
El Chapo's tortellini
is all his name
the Ferraris are part of a total of 30
supercars oh he got 30. including 14
Ferraris that were seized from Juan Jose
Valencia known as Falcon is he still
alive yes he is who is the alleged
Financial strategist of the clandel
Golfo Colombia's biggest criminal
organization yes according to Columbia's
authorities Valencia was extradited to
the U.S on July 27th after being
arrested at his house in May last year
on money laundering charges accused of
managing millions of dollars for Dario
Antonio usuga or otoniela I don't know
if I'm pronouncing it sure clandale golf
was top boss who was also recently
extradited to the U.S the Colombian
government will open the auction for the
Ferraris on October 25th next week the
lowest starting bid was set at just over
forty thousand dollars
first Ferrari on the list is a red 2020
812 super fast tortellini with less than
2 000 miles on it the second what's the
real name dude it's just a 2020 yeah
they're mostly like numbers right yeah
uh and then the the second is the silver
2019 488 spider with less than a
thousand miles of use and the last is a
white 2019 Ferrari Portofino with 1 000
miles on it so they're relatively you
know usable new that's dangerous though
man my freaking my dad had a co-worker
who was like this like he looks like a
cholo but he's not and then he um he
bought like a low rider like a used it
looked all like tricked out it had like
the wheels in the springs and everything
and then um he got shot at because the
Dude thought that it was the previous
owner oh [ __ ] they shot it at the car
because it's in uh he got shot and
survived because he takes 18th Street to
get to [ __ ] work they're like you
can't drive a car like that on 18th so
they found it instantly they were just
shooting at the car and he was like
and then at a red light the car in front
of him
um didn't go at the green and then a car
behind him uh they sandwiched him in
that's a [ __ ] head and then he just
sees the guy get out of the front car
and then sees in the mirror the other
guy get out of the back one same time oh
shoot how did he get away he just went
oh he just smashed him yeah is it I
thought he's like trying to bounce the
thoughts
jumps over it
that's why you don't buy cars with
criminal histories dude never ever ever
yeah the victors of the auction will be
announced by the Colombian government as
well oh so they want to get wild huh
dude you know what man if if the if the
freaking authorities did [ __ ] more like
the criminals like this stuff wouldn't
be a risk yeah they're so dumb they
don't learn nothing from criminals it's
like okay we're gonna do it with a lot
of red tape this is the Colombian resale
Market maybe they're the government's in
on it they want these people to get
murdered and then they just sell it
right back again dude hey pull up a
Ferrari 308
I would buy that if that was a narco car
yeah that's your favorite Ferrari car I
like to do it yeah why is the government
so dumb they literally announced they'll
be like okay so this hacker hacked her
computer this way we stopped it we still
don't know how to stop these four I
think it's amazing why does the
government do [ __ ] it's because
it's
punctuation
very very sexy it reminds me of a um
what's that car DeLorean Pantera a
DeLorean Anthony loves Panteras you like
Panteras why do I love Panteras because
the kid just complex used to be a
Pantera showroom that's right yeah
Panteras have that swoopy swoop look
yeah Panteras are awesome Elvis had a
panther he shot at it look at it dude
you don't know anything I want to see I
don't even know what you guys are
talking about oh that's a nice one pep
go dead tommaso Pantera that [ __ ] is
dope it's like it's super fat the back
goes like this you can see the motor
those are cool my dream car is probably
a 2003 Honda Prius I mean a Toyota Prius
can you look that one up
that [ __ ] does look pretty fast
I think you look back it's empty they
are there are a little bit of concerns
on like what uh the money is gonna be
you know when it's like the money's
gonna be going back to the people people
were like what what does that mean like
where's that money going but you know
the government and stuff is not exactly
explicit on uh how they're planning to
utilize those funds I wouldn't buy like
a narco anything I don't think like even
like if someone was offering me a house
Dirt Cheap I still wouldn't buy it just
because of the karma attached to it or
not the karma it's a real world risk of
like of being associated in some way
with like a criminal organization that
they're going to want it bad that's
still active if it was like if it was
like Italian if they were extinct a long
time ago or something yeah like if it's
historical like oh that's Bonnie and
Clyde's car yeah yeah pop out of the
[ __ ] thing and shoot you one of my
buddies has Saddam Hussein's pistol oh
so he was uh he was in one of like the
first games the first over there and you
know like it's as you like kind of like
um
advance
the the laws and Rules of Engagement
catch up to what's happening right so
like don't be like hey we've been
finding out like let's say uh dude's
been dressing up as chicks so
um if you see some broad shoulder dude
just blast them you know what I mean so
they have to through the engagement they
they establish the rules behind so in
the beginning it's like dude that's a
[ __ ] dog with a big stomach I think
there's an IND in there blast them so
they're just that's how they have to go
through War oh my God and so when they
uh when so so before they set up like
like TSA or whatever and that kind of
stuff over there when my buddy and his
Squad rated uh saddam's office he was
just like I just want to check see if I
could bring any memorabilia back and
then he pushed the bookshelf over and it
was underneath it
and he was like oh [ __ ] so he took apart
in pieces and they put it in like each
person had like a little piece in their
Duffle Bag Man wow
allegedly yeah this is one of those fall
off the truck scenarios huh yeah yeah
yeah yeah
but I'm like that's [ __ ] this is just
make believe we're just making up
stories yeah that's just a cool
hypothetical that your buddy exists it's
a movie me and Steve are writing yeah
yeah yeah
[Music]
[Music]